by hemoglobin is 8.0 after radiation. I have absolutely no energy, so that's going to be
effective. So having low hemoglobin tends to follow with having no energy, but there can be
other issues to have no energy. If you have fluid on your lungs, if you have that's going to put
pressure on your heart, that's going to decrease your heart pumping ability. That's going to decrease
your energy. Lots of things are going to affect that. I have a friend that frees dried an
organic liver and ovaries to help a mom with adenia after the baby was born. Is this something I
could use? Yes, you can do that as well. The beet powders can be beneficial for adenia as well
to get your hemoglobin out. Like we said, there's lots of different iron products out there that
are natural that you could use. Science or health just came up with an organ product, that's an
all-organic organ product, that's a powder that we have on our story. It's a brand new product that
they came up with. I was excited about it. It's all from New Zealand animals. It has good organ fluid
in it. Would you suggest that I just let it come up on its own? Well, no, you need to support it
to come up because we will build back up after radiation, which you need to help support that.
Last week, we said glutathione is good after radiation. After I have rough 2 supplements here,
but I haven't taken for a while. Would that be something to add? Yes, that would be something to
add, too. That's not going to. The glutathione is going to help get the hemoglobin up, but the glutathione
could help get rid of help with cell damage from the radiation. So, when you're trying to help healthy
cells stay alive after radiation, glutathione will get as your number one intercellular antioxidant
radiation is very strong, oxidized in Egypt.